There are only three basic primitives we ever send to the graphics processing
unit, points, line segments and triangles. Of these, triangles are by far the
most important. For example, just about everything you see in a 3D game is
ultimately made of triangles. Sometimes it's obvious where the triangles are
used, such as in Minecraft. Sometimes it's not, as in this shot from battlefield
3, captured by Duncan Harris at dead end thrills. We're going to touch on points
and lines only briefly so we can focus on triangles. Defining a point is simple,
you just specify a 3D location. For example, this point is at 0.4 in x, 0.2 in y
and 0.0 in z. By the way for all these examples I'm going to make the z values 0
but it can certainly have a different value. In 3D computer graphics you tend to
set all three coordinates x, y, and z even if you are mostly working in 2D. By
defining a second point we can create a line segment. The order of the points
does not matter.